[Inaudible].
The debacle and this Latin American country seems to be going on forever and a
day. And far from getting better.
This situation only seems to get worse and worse and worse,
Venezuela and GVP failed by our own 35% in 2019.
And yes, I did say 35% and the last six years alone,
the country has lost two thirds of its wealth. In other words,
we are talking about a rapid decline that has virtually no historical precedent
and the world,
especially given that this is not a country that is technically at war and my
friends, as we have already told you in previous videos,
one of the great reasons for the shocking failure of the Bali vari and political
and economic system has to do with its very high dependence on.
Oil. Because.
For years, when crude oil was selling for more than $100,
a barrel Hugo Chavez on his accolades were able to indulge themselves in all
kinds of wasteful spending. They scared away and punished private investment.
And despite this even went around with their heads,
held high boosting of their great prosperity. However,
since then things have changed a lot and have gotten much worse.
And now in 2020,
the coronavirus crisis has been the last straw for the Venezuelan oil industry
that as we will see has been treading water for years,
just take a look at this one fact viral event is wheeling oil sold for $9 and 90
cents in April, 2020.
And that's a long way down from the nearly $57 average pair viral in
2019.
And let's look closer because this isn't even the worst of it.
Check out this chart that shows us how Venezuelan oil production has evolved
over the past 10 years.
[Inaudible].
So you see my friends despite having the largest oil reserves in the world
today, the Boulevard and policy disaster has been a such magnitude.
The Venezuela today produces about six times less oil than it did just six years
ago.
By 2020 crude oil revenues will be more than 95% less than they were just
six years ago. And don't forget for a moment,
but we are talking about an economy that developed with basically a rentier
model,
the Boulevard and government never used the immense resources gained for the
sale of oil to develop or diversify its economy.
They didn't even invest in the very industry that was their golden goose.
It may be hard to believe,
but the truth is that oil production began to fall just when prices were.
Soaring.
We are not only talking about oil extraction, but also it's refining.
That is the process by which crude oil is transformed and diffuse in order to be
used. And here the numbers are no better. In fact,
the truth is that they are much, much worse. Over the past two decades.
Venezuela's refinement capacity has only fallen further.
The lack of investment maintenance and the practice of replacing professionals
with thousands of friends without competence.
Our training has caused Venezuelan refineries to have suffered a lot of
accidents, breakdowns and fires in recent years, I've gradually reduced.
Venezuela's refining capacity to basically zero.
In fact, 2020 began with news.
PD, VSA shuts its last two operating refineries in Venezuela. Um,
why Cardone?
Right? You heard that correctly.
One of the major players and the oil industry sector has been forced to close
its complexes. This includes the crown jewel, the Amway refinery,
the basis of what became one of the three largest all refining complexes on the
planet.
I know don't think this is a move to fight climate change or anything positively
that fires breakdowns, electricity costs,
and even a lack of oil or what finally forced the Venezuelan government to shut
down.
And that that's what explains why in a country that literally floats on oil.
We come across news stories like this one.
Iranian petrol tanker arrives in Venezuela in defiance of us financial
times.
Know what that is? What is the Boulevard and government going to do? Now,
if it is no longer able to extract and refine the minimum quantity of oil that
the Venezuelan economy needs in order to function,
how are they going to maintain their revolution now,
where are they going to get the resources they need to keep on breaking all the
high ranking officers in the army and government.
So they remain loyal well it's right here where the last card from Nicolas
Maduro is government comes into play
Because Wheeler has a region known as the Orinoco mining art that could count as
one of the largest deposits of mineral riches in the world.
According to Venezuelan government data,
this region could hold 7,000 tons of gold, which by the way,
it would make it the second largest reserve in the world.
Millions of tons of kimberlite diamonds, iron bauxite,
and another 40 high volume minerals, including Coulton,
which is currently one of the most prized minerals and the electronics industry.
If these figures are real,
which does not seem farfetched and Venezuela managed to exploit as potential on
a regular basis,
the country could raise billions of dollars each year dollars that could,
of course also be used to revive the oil industry,
the procurious national electricity system,
improve water treatment and distribution,
or be used to fund plans to industrialize and develop the Venezuelan economy.
In other words, when the time comes,
the Orinoco mining arts could play a key role in Venezuela's recovery.
Hold on just one moment because we have stumbled upon one inconvenient truth.
And so what does it, well,
these mining regions are anything but quiet and peaceful areas for doing
business. In fact, the pretty much the opposite. So my friends,
do you want to know more about this wild story? If so, I'll ask it correct.
The gold rush.
If there's one thing that characterizes the Venezuelan government is that they
wipe everything out, everything,
absolutely anything that implies a potential source of wealth,
they steal it or expropriate.
[Inaudible].
Mining sector was not going to be treated any differently.
What is the metal that the Vista government is most interested in today as
Germany have you already guessed?
Cool.
Only is gold scarce,
but it's one of the few minerals and practically the only one that has a high
value as soon as it is extracted, that is even without being processed. In fact,
native gold, which is what unrefined gold is called,
has so much value that is more sought after than a lollipop on the playground.
And that is precisely why the Venezuelan government back in Chavez Titan made
the control of its production distribution unseal. One of its main objectives,
a target that led Chavez to expropriate.
A lot of concessions held by private mining companies between 2008 and 2011,
especially Canadian ones. Something that by the way,
caused the Venezuelan government to be convicted by an international arbitration
tribunal. Of course incorrect us.
That's almost like getting a purple heart or military merits metal,
or if you don't know anything about the military,
imagine someone turns up at the party at 2:00 AM with a whole bunch of new boos,
but you know, it's the fight against imperialism. So let me ask you a question.
What do you think was the result in terms of production? Well,
not surprisingly gold production plummeted by 80% in just three years.
Exactly what you might've expected Boulevard and government has the uncanny
ability to destroy everything it touches,
but let's just take it a moment before we pass judgment because things have
changed somewhat in recent years,
not least because the material government knows that gold is one of the last few
cards that has to play in order to cling to power,
or should I say continue to looting the country with MPS.
Unity.
In recent years,
the material government has signed agreements with new mining companies,
mainly Russian and Chinese ones. And in 2015 they approved decree
2,165 11, the reinstatement of private companies and the sector. However,
companies can only operate through a joint venture with the state and always on
the condition that at least 55% of that company is under the control of the
Venezuelan government. And this way,
the state wants to continue to control production whilst benefiting from the
experience of mining companies,
at least those that are daring to enter such a risky venture.
What's more as recently as April, 2020,
the exploitation of gold mines and river areas was legalized up until that
point.
This was prohibitive actively because it implies very high environmental damage,
but Maduro,
he now wants no needs Gould by any means possible and as much as
possible.
[Inaudible].
It might not sound sort of strange,
but look closer because here there is a slight problem.
Most mineral holdings and particularly gold are illegal and in the hands of
criminal groups and traffickers who, and many cases are not exactly lately.
Perfect.
No, there are around 2000 mains of this tape operating and this is not
insignificant.
The illegal mining currently carried out by non-government groups represents a
good chunk of the gold production in the country. If not the majority of it,
these mines controlled by criminal groups and cleanse I've turned to Bali of our
state,
which is where the Orinoco mining art is located and to our region that is now
practically out war groups, such as that belonging to John Valdez,
AKA El Toto have become one of the government's greatest enemies by succeeding
and bringing the army,
the ELN or the national liberation army and former FARC guerrillas to their
knees. Yeah, that's right. The E L N and the X-bar forces as well.
These guerrilla groups that were once purely Colombian I've now become criminal
gangs of Colombian Venezuelan traffickers with whom that Chavista government
openly collaborates to give you an idea.
It is estimated to have all the proceeds from Alyssa activities obtained by the
ELN. 60% comes from illegal mining in Venezuela, and yes,
also in Columbia.
And this is something we will get into in a few moments because the truth is,
is that there is a lot and I mean a lot going on here.
Well,
we're going to review how gold production works in Venezuela and what role the
central bank plays in this whole story.
As we will see the Venezuelan law States that all gold production must be
delivered to the central bank of Venezuela,
which manages the gold reserves and the exports of the extracted gold to be
traded. In addition, in order to export this mineral,
the operation needs to be approved by the national assembly,
a legal requirement.
The [inaudible] government has ignored since the Venezuelan parliament fell into
the hands of the opposition. But by far,
the biggest problem is that due to the gigantic smuggling and illegal mining
networks that may take gold out of Venezuela, mainly through Brazil and Ghana,
it is estimated that only one out of every three or four tons extracted are
delivered to the Venezuelan central bank.
So an effect the government has already lost control over most of the gold
trades and of course of that income.
And that is why the Vista government of Nicolas Maduro has declared war on
illegal mining. They don't want to end it,
but essentially to restore their power and take over the activity.
Or in other words, the idea is not to solve the problem,
but to replace the key player.
Yeah.
The ugliest part of the story appears maintaining States,
especially Boulevard States have descended into a kind of violent anarchy or
government criminals and smuggling, criminals, Kelly, each other for control.
It's a terrible scenario that is causing Savage killings.
Like the ones we were used to watching on television or in Hollywood films,
the victims of these killings are miners from both sides,
collaborators carriers, and of course all kinds of mercenaries and ringleaders.
So do you want to come with us to this place,
to find out more about what's going on and to see how the balance is shifting?
Of course you do. So let's get started.
Cool.
The Venezuelan government on the ELN gorillas and ex FOC forces have generated a
curious criminal symbiosis to take back control of the Orinoco gold.
And if the presence of these criminal groups already casts a dark shadow.
Imagine if we add to the mix, a corrupt military, or more specifically,
very corrupt taught officers the military,
instead of working to ensure that gold and his profits improve the country's
economic situation are dedicated to filling their own pockets and have no qualms
about working and collaborating with criminal gangs. And it turns out surprise,
surprise. That's exactly what's going on.
The methods the military uses to fill their pockets in this particular criminal
ecosystem are known to be similar to those used by the ELN gorillas and the ex
FARC forces.
They collect a kind of tool in the form of gold Colton diamonds or whatever is
extracted something like an enchained tax on the illegal groups.
They extract the ore. And you know,
if you aren't willing to jump through the hoop, then say goodbye,
because they're after you. And then full out war is just around the corner,
but pay attention here because don't think that these are the only players
Venezuela's state owned mining company.
Minerva is also fully implicated in all of this murky history.
You're talking about a company that is sanctioned by the United States for
illegally enriching Maduro and the trivia stick gang.
It has gone from extracting gold itself to being a mere channel for illegal
gold. These days.
Most of the gold that McNevin brings to the central bank of Venezuela to sale or
take out of the country,
comes from the extractions made by criminal groups controlled by the.
Government.
That is to say in Venezuela, the extraction of many minerals and above all else,
gold, no longer depends on the government concessions or private companies,
but simply on illegal groups.
This is what the Boulevard and revolution has convected Venezuela into,
but let's not go off track.
Let's get back to the goal that the Venezuelan government manages and those
become its last great source of income.
The point is the Jew to international sanctions.
The options that the Venezuelan government have to export their gold have also
been considerably reduced. For example, before the sanctions,
much of the native gold was sent to Switzerland for refining before being sold
or deposited in the coffers of the central bank.
But now after the U S sanctions,
the Swiss have become suspicious of this activity. Uh,
no longer accept gold from Venezuela and as history buffs might know,
it takes an awful lot for the Swiss to not accept gold.
That is something that forced Venezuelan leaders to change their routes today.
The gold that the Venezuelan government manages to export is sent to places like
Turkey, Dubai, or Uganda. No,
really you Gunda listen up.
73 Tons of Venezuelan gold slew to Turkey, Dubai,
and Uganda insight crime.
According to information from insight crane,
it is believed that the Venezuelan gold could be leaving the country on
scheduled flights of Turkish airlines,
the largest Turkish Isla and flying between Turkey and Venezuela flight started
in 2016 with three weekly services and were extended to five just one
year later. Does that sound at all suspicious? So what happens next?
What happens once the goal arrives in Turkey?
Well,
it appears that many of the refined gold bars later end up well protected in
Iran,
which is a loyal ally of the Venezuelan regime or their deposits to banks in
Singapore. Many of these operations of course,
are framed as sales to companies over dubious reputation and serve either to
fill their own pockets or to pay for the supplies and suppliers.
The Venezuelan government needs to stay in power. But as we said before,
it's not only Turkey that is used. Uganda has become another priority.
Destination Venezuelan gold is refined there by the African gold refinery,
a company owned by the Belgian company go it's gold, which is based in Dubai.
Turkey.
Uganda, Dubai, what are racket by the way,
this Belgium company is suspected of being part of an international blood gold
trafficking network.
What does the term you use for gold illegally extracted in war zones or for
whose trade and controlled? There are arms disputes between criminal gangs.
I mean, come on. Just what is going on in the Orinoco mining arch?
The worst part is that all these million dollar transactions,
regular Venezuelans see virtually nothing because sadly,
most of the gold that leaves the country under the pretext of refining,
it never returns or even enters the central bank event. As we look again,
neither in the form of gold bars, nor in the form of cash deposits,
it just disappears. So where could it possibly go?
I'm pretty sure that you already know the answer to that though. Don't you,
what's more,
don't forget that between two thirds and three quarters that is most of all the
gold production in the country is not controlled by the government or at least
not through legitimate channels set by the law.
So.
In a nutshell,
the corruption of the Vista regime and the state's lack of control over the
smugglers causes Venezuelans to lose hundreds of tons of gold, hundreds,
and hundreds of billions of dollars are taken and mined with impunity from the
country, unfortunately is not only impoverishing Venezuela,
but is bathing the country and blood as well. And it's not just about the gold.
It's a very similar story with the diamonds or the Venezuelan Colton.
And of course, let's not forget the governments,
other source of income drug trafficking,
but that's something we covered in this video.
So my friends,
the Boulevard revolution has turned Venezuela into a great mafia States to the
point of that note,
the Boulevard and government itself is on its knees because it is no longer able
to control those criminal groups operating within its own country.
So now the question is,
do you think that Venezuela will be able to take advantage of all these immense
riches to finally get back on its feet?
Is there any solution to institutionalized corruption and organized crime in the
country? Could Venezuela have already reached the point of no return as always.
We ask the questions and leave it up to you to leave your answers,
stick them down in the comments below. Anyway,
we really hope you enjoyed this video. Please hit like if you did,
and don't forget to subscribe and for brand new videos,
have you had the little London there you'll get updates whenever release new
ones. Don't forget to check out our friends at the reconsider media podcast too.
They provided the vocals in this episode, or there were not my dulcet tones.
Also this channel is possible because of patriarchy and our patrons on that
platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting our mission of providing independent
political coverage. And as always, I'll see you next time.
If you want to learn more about politics and world affairs,
and here's some more of my lovely check out the reconsidered podcast where we
don't do the thinking for you find
reconsider@wwwdotreconsideredmedia.com or on Apple or Google play or your
favorite podcast.